la ceinture fléchée était le symbole
canadien français ou le métis oui
bienvenue à paroles autochtone si ces
milices au moulin depuis cette semaine
je réponds à la question de jazz et
c'est une question qui est excellent
parce qu'on me la pose très souvent
quand je rencontre des gens dans le
public
la ceinture fléchée si un symbole très
canadien français on pense juste au
portrait du patriote avec sa grosse
ceinture fléchée ça ça va revenir comme
un réflexe dans la tête de beaucoup
québécois mais quand les gens se rendent
compte que les métis ou s'ils utilisent
le symbole de la ceinture fléchée pour
représenter leur identité souvent cette
ceinture doutzen une distinction c'est
carrément des fois un petit drapeau bleu
avec le 8 qui représente l'infini qui
représente la nation métisse mais
comment est ce que la nation métisse qui
est une nation autochtone qui reconnaît
la ceinture fléchée comme un symbole
autochtones pour eux et les nation
canadienne française qui sont maintenant
au québec peuvent avoir le même symbole
est là je vais vous parler de
syncrétisme culturel
on parle de l'appropriation culturelle
on parle d'adoption culturel mais le
syncrétisme culturel c'est qu'en deux
concepts qui viennent de deux nations
différentes mais qui partagent le même
territoire se mélangent et commence à se
compléter la ceinture fléchée en est un
parce que la ceinture et les un tissage
à la main fait avec un modèle de chevron
et 2.2 fléchi qui existait aussi chez
les premières nations ce tissage de
existait on faisait des ceintures ou des
str ap
pour pouvoir utiliser pendant le portage
d'ailleurs certains de ces strap le et
eti certains été fait avec des les
causes de boulot pour s'appuyer sur le
front et servait à empêcher que le poids
des choses sur les épaules sur le dos
fatigue ou créent des hernies chez les
portageurs et c'est pour ça aussi que
les coureurs des bois ont utilisé la
ceinture fléchée qui pouvaient atteindre
jusqu'à deux mètres de longueur pour
transporter des ballots de fourrure
alors c'est devenu entre les deux
nations qui s'échangeait 1 bien des
échanges culturels qui est apprécié par
les présentations parce que les couleurs
étaient extrêmement voyante et bigarré
et ça c'était quelque chose qui était
apprécié par les progressions on peut le
voir d'ailleurs encore aujourd'hui si on
va dans les parents on aime les choses
qu'ils sont
et coloré mais la ceinture fléchée comme
projet d'identité
c'est quand même venu parce qu'on
voulait représenter avec nos vêtements
notre fierté et la couleur représenté
aussi certaines nations d'ailleurs je
prends juste l'exemple au québec
montréal avait beaucoup plus de rouge
québec avait beaucoup plus de bleu trois
rivières toutes les communautés avaient
des couleurs qui était très différente
alors le syncrétisme culturel a permis
que justement ce même bien culturel soi
même ces mêmes objets a pu servir à deux
nations et les deux nations dans les
faits aujourd'hui utilisent la ceinture
fléchée mais ça représente quand même
quelque chose de très important ça
représente le filon francophones qui a
traversé le canada parce que les nations
métis ce sont quand même les enfants qui
ont et qu'ils sont nés des premières
relations entre les français étaient des
opérateurs et les programmations qui
était sur le territoire donc sa grande
soeur représente la francophonie mais ça
représente aussi dans l'autre sens
identité autochtone j'espère déjà ce que
tu peux voir là dedans quelque chose qui
représente le vivre ensemble beaucoup
plus positif et qui nous éloignent
beaucoup de l'appropriation culturelle
malheureusement qu'on doit décrié encore
aujourd'hui n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer
des questions n'hésitez pas surtout à
partager ses vidéos
je vous souhaite une belle semaine